Marc-Alexandre ?
Marca ?
Oui ?
Dis-moi, je me demandais, peux tu m'expliquer pourquoi il fait nuit ?
Oui, je peux te l'expliquer.
Chaque jour quand on regarde le ciel
le matin, on voit le soleil qui se lève d'un côté.
On le voit monter dans le ciel
pendant toute la matinée,
puis l'après-midi, on le voit redescendre dans une
autre direction le soir se coucher
et ensuite il fait nuit !
Enfin, je sais qu'il fait nuit lorsque le soleil se couche !
Moi, ce que j'aimerais
savoir c'est pourquoi ?
Pour que tu comprennes bien, on va faire comme si on
observait la Terre vue depuis l'Espace
sur ce schéma tu reconnais la Terre
notre planète et le soleil.
Le soleil c'est un peu comme une grosse
lampe qui ferait de la lumière,
il éclaire, ce qui fait qu'en
permanence sur la Terre il y a une
moitié de la Terre qui est éclairée par
le soleil pendant que l'autre moitié se
retrouve plongée dans le noir,
plongée dans la nuit.
D'accord et alors, pourquoi on passe de la nuit au jour
puis du jour à la nuit et ce en permanence ?
Imaginons que la Terre ce
soit un peu comme un grand manège qui
serait situé à côté d'un lampadaire. Si tu te trouves sur le manège et que le
manège se met à tourner. Tu vas donc
passer d'un côté éclairé à celui qui ne
l'est pas puis de nouveau du côté éclairé. Pour la Terre, c'est la même chose.
La Terre tourne, elle tourne sur elle-
même, c'est ce qui fait que nous sommes
parfois dans le côté jour puis dans le
côté nuit puis de nouveau dans le côté jour, etc...
Ce mouvement de la
Terre qui tourne sur elle même,
on appelle ça la rotation. La terre met
24 heures pour faire un tour sur elle-même.
c'est pour ça qu'on a des journées de 24 heures.